what is up what is good homies how you
livin it left go show and we are as soon
as I get off this scent I am laying down
future bets out the wazoo I have a very
special guest coming up in just a little
bit that's why this seat is empty I'm
excited to tell you who is going to be
there but I'd rather show you in a
second but first before we get into it I
want to give out a shout out to all the
homies watching on YouTube listening to
the podcast if you signed up for the LF
gl the let's freaking go League aka the
left go football Grand League got over
1200 people signed up to play fantasy
football if you haven't heard from a
commissioner yet you got to hit up
William Ezell go on instagram at wge -
he'll make sure that you get into the
league you need to get also with the
bets
I mean crack is out there we've had him
on the podcast many times he's gonna
help me make my future bets as is Warren
sharp and on the podcast coming out
Thursday I will share with you guys all
of my tickets as I put them up into the
studio we have a lot of stuff to talk
about hard knocks Antonio Brown helmets
it's wild
but I think I'd like to introduce my
guest because I want to hear what he has
to say about it as well so please in the
beautiful city of Las Vegas Nevada
a man that has a Heisman Trophy a man
that captivated the nation and its
hearts and minds and had LeBron and
Drake becoming his best friend and today
he's about to become a member of the 33%
I want to lift up that door and it's
time for Johnny frickin football can I
get a round of applause for Johnny
football please how are you pal is it is
it still Johnny football is it John I
think you should rebrand and come back
as Jack football and just leave
everybody throw a loop I didn't get a
chance to watch you walk out
here and I'm upset because I want to see
what it's like is it like a sea parting
like what is it like for you at this
point but this specially in Vegas it's
probably a little bit more chill these
days but Vegas is always a good time you
never know how you're gonna run into I
mean I'm sure people are saying that
about you though I'm sure they're like
holy crap I was in Caesars and then
Johnny Manziel walked I was walking by
this podcast as I was going to place a
sports game what is this city like for
you good memories in the city I love
Vegas
cities can be as wild as your
imagination really want it to be you you
experience things that I mean I'm sure
people come up to you and they just say
what's the craziest thing you've ever
experienced like what's the most common
question about that time of your life
that you get probably uh you know who
would you want to meet or who haven't
you met yeah and I'm like you know what
I kind of went after that and tried to
meet everybody that I could possibly
could especially when I was in college
and yeah around that time it was social
media it was easy I talked to talk to a
ton of people and met a lot of people so
you know it's been it's been really cool
was it DM sliding was that like I mean
it was Drake did it start from the DMS
that just came from just just kind of a
just a fluke relationship but just fine
you know hoodies on a website he noticed
my name and and ended up talking to one
of his boys and creating a relationship
from there and it's funny looking back
seven years later and you know hearing a
song about it and being able to you know
reach out to a guy consider a friend so
so your turn now you went on the ovo
website bought a hoodie they saw Johnny
Manziel on the shipping address and said
I'm gonna reach out to this guy yeah
they pretty much said you know we
appreciate you supporting the brand and
buying you know there's a lot of people
in your position who would probably DMS
or ask for free things yeah it was just
something that I liked and something I
was going to support whether and you
just came out about right oh yeah it's
not going anywhere let me can I see it
man I remember when you got that man and
people are freaking out you everything
you did people freaked out that was that
funny thing back in the day but yeah was
it a point where you were like hey guys
I'm gonna put out an Instagram video
want to see the news cycle change from
today I would
I had this thing with my friends when I
was in college where if anybody kind of
got on my bad side or you know came at
me the wrong way a little bit I would
tweet their phone number out just on
Twitter and kind of make it seem like it
was supposed to be a DM but send it to
all my followers it would probably have
to change their phone absolutely
absolutely their phone would just blow
up for the rest of the day I have
friends that didn't change our number
that still have people calling them
asking if it's many years later at this
point the power that you have it was
I've never seen anything like this like
we were talking about this back there
but like the Antonio Brown stuff that's
going on right now let's talk about
someone other than you really quick what
do you think about all this with the
helmet and everything that's been going
on is someone that knows what it's like
to be in the middle of something like
this what are you what is your take on
this whole Antonio Brown thing yeah I
think there's just there's certain
things that the media likes to get ahold
to a little bit and you know they they
have to have a story and they have to
make it a big deal you know I think
obviously him missing some time has been
a big deal for the Raider you know him
not being there him like we spoke about
earlier being the spark for that team
and really a staple for what they need
to try and go and have a big year they
want him there but you know at the end
of the day for me you know he's
comfortable with the helmet it's it's a
weird change for him obviously and it's
caused some problems but that's awesome
there was a goal of the Man United game
and those guys are excited about it
well nothing man you to that point
though Antonio Brown goes on television
and I would say 90% of these people are
gonna go he's crazy
they're gonna they're gonna project it
on to him you watch it and you go you
try and see through it I would imagine
yeah a little bit I mean you want to see
both sides of it a little bit you're
obviously look at the radar side of it
they want him there you know they paid
for they paid for him to be there paid
for him to get him there and you know
he's a huge piece to them wanting to go
win their division and try and get to
the playoffs and make a push he is that
piece for them but in France ownio Brown
he wants to feel like he's safe and
comfortable and be able to go out and
perform at his best and obviously to him
the helmet makes a little bit of a
difference all right I want to get back
to you what were you at right now what
do you want to do like what's what's
John Mann's
2.0 like were you out right now you know
I'm just kind of just taking things slow
I'm enjoying you know the opportunities
that are coming my way whether it's
coming out here and doing something like
this I'm just kind of enjoying the
summer a little bit you know I'm keeping
myself in good shape and just waiting
for the next opportunity and just trying
to be patient and whatever that is
I saw you went was a Canadian Football
League and then a AFL and I saw you had
the note to all the football players
which was keep all the money you got
you're not getting any more checks like
I felt like everybody the house was
fallen and you were like I've seen stuff
like this before
what was that experience being in the
AFL and did you think it could work her
did it always seem like it was gonna
come crashing down no I thought it was I
thought it was a great thing you know I
was there for two weeks and just you
know it was just bare bones getting back
to the basics of football and and know
guys who hadn't had very much experience
with the NFL and hadn't got a chance to
be in a training camp which I was
fortunate enough to be in for two years
they don't know the nature of the
business like that and when you come
from college and get into the next
league of playing and money comes into
it and there's everything else you don't
always know better and a lot of guys
there we're just expecting this to last
for for the end of it and very quickly
going out to practice and then being
told to come back in and then it
disappeared
you know at the blink of an eye you know
these guys are you know expecting three
or four more checks or name checks and
more money that they're gonna use to go
into the offseason thinking they're
getting ready for next season
yeah and that disappeared like that so
you went out to the practice field and
they said guys come back in yeah it was
kind of just a weird little bit of setup
walking pads on walking to practice for
the day and it's kind of just a weird
weird feeling kind of around the locker
room some guys were there it wasn't in a
packed house like it normally was and
yeah pretty much say we're gonna have a
team meeting called up League was was
dissolved within you know really 24 to
48 hours
that's wild so what did you do I ended
up staying in Memphis for another week
and then and then I'm heading back to
Texas but you know I got a chance I was
in a really cool quarterback room at
Christian Hackenberg and
you know Brandon a couple of the rest of
the guys that were in there that I
really liked so you know before they
took off we hung out play some golf in
the next couple days enjoyed some time
together before we all went our separate
ways so I thought the league had a lot
of potential I thought it had a I think
it has a place still to this day you
know the a lot of people don't
understand there's so many guys out
there that it was twenty nine hundred
people on rosters right now and the NFL
and in a matter of two weeks that's
about to be cut down any guys that we've
all heard of oh yeah it's guys that we
know will fight for the roster spots
but every year we have a few more
thousand guys coming into the league and
is it because I think everyone's gonna
now root for the XFL to work - how many
guys are there and then how do they keep
that dream alive because I'm sure you
reach a point or you're like it's just
over man like I just can't do it anymore
yeah of course I mean every year like
you said there's another thousand guys
coming in and then you know four or five
years before those guys that are still
hanging on getting pushed out so you
know it's up to you and how much you
really feel that you have a chance to
keep going and keep playing I think
leagues like the XFL in the AF get
people more open more chance cuz the
more film you get at that point the more
time you get on the field to show
somebody something that the better your
chances are getting to the NFL have you
had doubts in this journey maybe along
the lines a little bit just at times but
you know I feel my situation has been
unique and and if I can continue to play
and continue to try and you know just
get film and get better and get as many
reps as I can that's what's best for me
I need you in Houston for the XFL like
what do I need to do to like rally up
the troops that like to get you on this
team you know I don't really know what
it's gonna take you know I'm just kind
of waiting sitting back and letting you
want themselves out I want to continue
to play yes for sure can I go you get
drafted out of Killeen you get drafted
to Cleveland in your mind were you like
I know you sent the text to down Logan's
we're gonna wreck this league were you
in your mind like I'm gonna [ __ ] be
the guy that takes the Cleveland Browns
to the promised land like from the very
beginning did you believe that I
was gonna be it wasn't gonna be that the
quickest turnaround you know your ever
you know as I get into a training camp I
saw just from where I was at just from a
football standpoint my knowledge of the
game coming from college to the NFL was
a huge huge difference you know what you
have to to know and learn to get ready
for an excellent oh [ __ ] moment that
first Charlie of course
you sit there and you're going through
protections and all these guys are
bullets and blitzing and there's seven
DBS on the field and you're just trying
to point you know who the Mike
linebacker is you know you definitely
sit back and get a little bit
overwhelmed that maybe discouraged at
times I had heard that in that Buffalo
game that last Drive I heard the plays
were coming in the helmet pretty much
like hey look to the guy on the Left
look to the guy on the right like that's
how quickly it was moved that you kind
of just got thrown in there that it was
like we're gonna talk this out in your
helmet as I think was Kyle Shanahan and
as we like what happened on that drive
because I remember you scored and
everyone's like here we [ __ ] go what
happened on that drive though I remember
I called the first play backwards and
half the guys were rolling out on a roll
out to the left I'm rolling out to the
right and ended up just throwing it away
is just kind of one of those Oh nervous
jitters of getting a game for the first
time I think in an NFL game but Kyle did
a great job of helping me really
understand things and try and slow it
down and make it as easy as possible he
was amazing and is it true that he was
kind of in there being like throw to the
guy to the left Kyle was the kind of guy
that not a lot of people know this about
a college Hanahan but he is probably by
far the most knowledgeable football guy
I've ever been around just whether it's
coaching and get coached the o-line the
tight ends the running backs the
receivers and the quarterbacks all at
the same time whether it be technique or
just little things and little nuances
yeah he's just been around the game for
so long that he knows almost every part
of it oh I'm sure you came in and the
first offense of mine you meet is
college Hanahan and you're like the NFL
is crazy because he's like a wizard
it's like him McVeigh Peyton McDaniels
and then like an Andy Reid and then like
everybody else but I'm sure you met him
and he's telling you things and he's
like it'll be open trust me
ya know he was that kind of way he
was you know you saw him you know it
it's time throughout the league where
he's one of those guys that will put his
hands out before the you know the balls
even snapped just based off coverage and
alignment and you know one person being
out of alignment just a little bit so
that's how detailed it comes down to
when he gets to that having been in that
city and having been a star in that city
how do you think this works with Odell
just a person of his energy in Cleveland
I think odo gets a bad rap at times I
think him being in New York always being
in the spotlight and I think he at times
probably it's a little emotional and
lets it get to him a little bit but I
think him being in Cleveland now even
with all the craziness of him being
there and the hype that they do have I
think he'll be able to handle it really
really well and I think they're they're
you know poised for a good run for
success for sure when you're the biggest
fish in a small pond like that like when
you're in Cleveland like are there
restaurants you can go to or like you
leave your apartment and it's like mass
hysteria yeah it was it was you know
Saturdays or Sundays is you have home
games and things like that you kind of
know your surroundings a little bit but
you know for the most part you know it
is kind of a pretty quiet town during
that the early days of the week and you
know outside of having home games you
know when I was there LeBron was though
they're just getting back as well so the
hype and craziness of the city was even
more of LeBron and the drakes and all
that was there a moment whether it was a
party and event courtside somewhere that
you look back and you were like damn and
that was that was a hell of a ride yeah
I mean I still look back and and you
know think about things and laugh a
little bit at times and things that
makes you laugh the most or just just
the wildness of it all you know I'm from
a town of 20,000 people pretty small and
then you know in the whole country of
Texas you know just to be able to get to
this stage I mean I would have come here
and do things like this are still
surreal for me at time so it's it's
still you know just all of it in general
it's crazy to think of you know where I
was from high school being there five
years later doing some some really cool
things alright I need you to walk me
through you walk into a restaurant how
does everybody in the restaurant change
because you experienced on that none of
us will ever experience you walk in
inhuman
react like do you notice people start
whisper like where are you just
completely oblivious to it all you know
at times I probably keep my head down a
little bit and just try and cruise
through and just get a meal or just
chill like anybody else would I mean I'm
walking into a restaurant yesterday and
and just kind of pick my head up to look
for a seat and a lady literally put your
finger right in my face and says my name
out loud in front of the whole
restaurant so it's kind of you know hit
or miss depending on where I'm at a
little bit of course and then what about
the creepy [ __ ] that are like
recording you on the low can you feel it
oh absolutely
like that was always my issue with what
was happening with you it's like who are
these dudes like low-key recording you
at a pool party and stuff yeah we could
be somewhere like that and there's
thousands of girls around everywhere
right and there's just guys that want to
come up to other guys and take pictures
and put it on the internet right away so
you know it's funny people are wired a
little bit thing or is that going away
um it's it's I kind of keep myself away
from it a little bit you know now I'm
try and hide away from it a little bit
just because of you know problems that
I've run into in the bath I just try to
learn from some of the past situations
and navigate through them better it's
just [ __ ] because you're getting
this transactional thing with humans
where people are running up to you and
they're like I need your photo for my
Instagram or I need your photo for my
likes and it that's got to eventually
take away the human nature part of it
completely oh it does I think you know
athletes at times aren't even looked at
like that anymore you know they're
they're just public figures to in a
sense and not really we're just going
out with their family or going to eat or
just doing things as anybody else does
on a daily basis like I'm sure you had
moments with like Drake and LeBron where
you were like I actually feel
comfortable here because these guys get
what I'm going through right now yeah of
course which is wild to think of a guy
from a twenty thousand person town you
have more in common with Drake and
LeBron than the dudes you grew up down
the street I mean I was definitely still
too small fish and around those guys for
sure but you know I definitely got to
see a lot of things just being around
them how they
how they handle the whole situation you
know they're pretty pretty good at their
routine to get in and out and
eliminating the problems that come from
you know just just being in that role
and being who they are speaking of a guy
it's eliminating problems very excited
for your but your buddy Josh Gordon
right now he in my mind is in this
perfect situation in New England Tom
Brady calming force Belichick never
gonna waver you know this guy where do
you think we are with Josh cuz I'm all
in I believe that he's turning the
corner right now do you see that as well
yeah I have all the faith in the world
and Josh you know I saw something
yesterday I think trust gordon is
averaging the most yards per catch from
tom bait brady over anybody that's ever
played with him over Gronk over it's
over anybody and he you know only got to
play a handful of games where he really
got in and got a chance to play you know
as much as he probably wants there's a
custom too but you know I have all the
faith in the world and JG especially now
that he's back he's being reinstated and
especially where he's at you know with
the type of team he's at the way they
run the organization I think is is good
for him and you know they haven't really
wavered on him you know eventually since
he disappeared last year they're still
stuck around on it were you and Josh
living together Josh and me spent some
time together in the office he's in 2016
for probably three or four months and
you know in Cleveland we were you know
together quite a bit or you know a good
friend and a guy that I still you know
care about to this day and hope he does
you know really well I had Austin Hooper
from the Falcons on and he was talking
about plays and practice that Julio
Jones would make that they would just
eventually became normal but beginning
their mouths were on the floor what was
your first oh [ __ ] moment with how
incredible Josh Gordon was he just look
at how big he is and just the way he's
able to just you know he's got that
ability in that height that you just
don't see from a lot of people and
luckily I got a chance to be around Mike
Evans when I was in college so I got to
see some things but you know him and him
and Josh Gordon or just those guys are
special I really want like a play
whether it's Josh Gordon or Mike Evans
whichever one comes first where you saw
it in practice and un
that's not a human that's a cyborg yeah
no our mine and Mike's redshirt freshman
year before we ever even played a game
at a.m. we got to a point where you know
we were doing really really well and
practice on scout team against our first
team defense my redshirt year and he
would just do things that were just
regularly just going up back shoulder
one-handed catches and just sticking it
like it's nothing this guy's 17 years
old at the time and it only played two
years of football
now you look up Mike Evans and you go
exactly and it doesn't surprise me one
bit
no do you where do you put him in terms
of NFL wide receivers I put him in and I
put him you know and the top five always
from what he's done he's hardly missed
any games a thousand yards and every
single season he's been in the league I
think he's probably you know one of the
most underrated guys no week but he goes
out every year he has a thousand yards
he has seven eight touchdowns and
consistency that's what he's brought for
the last five or six years he's been in
the league so I gotta admit I'm getting
ready and I'm looking up I mean this is
all [ __ ] about you and I'm I'm reliving
all of these different things that you
went through but candidly like I don't
really want to [ __ ] bring him up to
you but there so it was captivating bro
like it was it was going to Vegas and
dressing up like Billy you know what I
mean with like the the wig and all that
stuff and like it was the most
entertaining [ __ ] I've ever seen
and so the whole time um I'm like
alright I'm a little bit older than you
and the whole time I'm going man if I
was an NFL star I would want to be
partying to like the whole time I was
like if I was in my 20s I'd want the
full Superstar experience and I think
not until I started here in rosenhouse
coming out and they were they were sort
of like we're concerned about you but
the whole time I was like you know
Johnny do your [ __ ] thing man were
you I mean I'm sure you were like I've
earned this for a long time too was that
I mean that wasn't really a question I'm
just kind of curious it just got to a
point where you know the main thing was
was football and you know there
always there's always that four or five
months in the offseason where you do get
a chance to wind down and get a break
and get away I think there's the time in
place for it and you know during the
season you know I should have had a
little bit more accountability to the
guys that were in the locker room and
the guys that were around and it been in
Cleveland and you know I look back on it
probably with a lot of regrets at times
and but you learn from your mistakes and
you learn what you go through you know I
was a young kid who probably could have
you know really used a couple years that
I had left in college I probably rushed
into that a little bit and looking back
at it now there's you know there's
nothing wrong with that I had a lot of
people around me that could have helped
me if I would have just listened you
know you're at that point where you're
young and you don't always want to
listen and you know sitting back today
at 26 years old as I look back on things
you know you have regrets you have
things you wish you would have done
different but nevertheless you just kind
of keep keep moving forward and keep
going at the same point I think you're
gonna be wiser than ever because I think
nobody learns [ __ ] unless you go through
[ __ ] and you've seen you've seen people
that pretended to love you and you also
saw people turn their back on you like I
bet you learned a lot about your people
really cool there's a lot of people that
were around every single day that I
haven't heard from you know in a long
time his things started to change and
you know that's okay I still I still
have a lot of people that you know
they're at the beginning and still are
now so yeah I mean I and not a lot of
people get to experience that a lot of
people they go through their whole lives
thinking that that's their day one of
course and they don't even show up for
the big things you know yeah how tight
your circle right now pretty small as
small as it's probably ever been you
know I've really constricted that and
really just kind of you know tightened
it up even more than I ever have in the
past just like I'm doing right now
people bring up your past you relive it
I know that you've been through a lot of
mental work and all that was was there a
moment whether it was talking to
somebody or someone spoke to you where
it clicked or has it just been growth
over time that's probably been a little
bit of growth over time I think it's
just been a little bit of just trying to
tell myself that you know I don't
always know what's best and it's okay to
ask for help a little bit at times I
want you to know too that like I'm
saying all this [ __ ] judgment-free um
I'm someone that I'm gonna go to the
tables I'm gonna die hard I'm someone
that I drink I smoke I do what I do what
I do but the amount of times that I look
at myself in the mirror and need
discipline or I go to people and I crave
authenticity
I appreciate you because you're human
and I know that you were doing your
podcast before and you're willing to
talk to people about it as you talk
about your past does it reinforce your
future maybe a little bit as I go back I
think it just kind of helps me move
forward in the decisions that I make a
little bit I guess you wouldn't change
it for anything no I I might you know
there's things I wish I would have
probably just listened a little bit more
instead of being as stubborn as I was at
times but and you know the world we live
in in the way the world works is you
don't get a chance to go back and do it
differently so you know you do get that
one shot you know hopefully moving
forward you get another opportunity and
you don't do the same thing you did
before still wanna play football still
on the horizon media are you still doing
the podcast but we'll see okay if let's
say let's say you get into how about
this you get back in the NFL and you
have a few more years and you enjoy it
and then you're able to put football to
rest you're a young dude bro where do
you have you thought about next have you
thought about future you know I haven't
as much as I you know I might should at
this time just because I'm trying to
stay focused and enjoy enjoying what is
now and I feel in the past I've kind of
outgrown myself a little bit as far as
like where am I thinking is I've looked
down the road down the road down the
road and missed some things that are
happening now how are you keeping
yourself in shape right now who you
training with who you working out with
yeah just pretty much the same schedule
that I'm on every offseason a little bit
just kind of just keeping the same
routine and you know I've learned a good
routine learned what it is especially
not being in I know what guys are doing
right now what camps like you obviously
can't recreate that no matter what you
do but you know you still stay on top of
it and still try and keep a good
schedule as you look around the NFL
which teams do you really like right
just fan Manziel who sticks out to you
you know I really think this is gonna be
a good year for the Cowboys you feeling
it I like to cover you're a Cowboys fan
at heart right yeah you know I have been
but I just I just feel like you know
they're finally getting to the point
where they're getting over that hump I
feel like they've made some moves on
defense that they haven't made in the
past that's maybe been a little bit
right Frederick is back at center I
could send what they got for the
suspension the great offensive line you
know we'll see what happens with the
Zeke and situation as as someone that I
remember you were like I want to play
for the Cowboys at one point during your
career Jerry came out after Tony Pollard
did well in the preseason game it's @z
coup that got back to Zeke and Zeke and
is his agent I guess are upset about it
we all talked about how they built the
offense around Zeke and I always wonder
why is Jerry still talking like he's a
billionaire and I don't want to question
them too much but at the same point like
why are these negotiations happening out
front how do you think this ends with
Zeke you know I think I think the
Cowboys probably have no choice at the
end of the day but the fam and hopefully
that he's not asking for too much to
wear it you know hinders them signing
what they want to do with the rest of
their team offensively you have three
guys who all need to get signed and only
so much money that they have to do it
especially with you know pain a couple
guys on the o-line what they pay him
paying at the end what they pay him you
know so there's only so much money to go
around so it'll be interesting I'm
curious to see if they can sign all
three especially with guys who were
trying to you know max out you know
their deals right now what pay 40 yeah I
think I think that could probably be a
little bit you know blown out of
proportion I don't know if there is a
quarterback in the league right now who
could probably get to 40 outside of
Patrick mahomes and that's just you know
you're two years in you want to MVP
you're gonna command some dollars for
sure did you have any crossover with any
like how many NFL starting quarterbacks
right now in that sec days were you
battling with I don't know if there are
any suc quarterbacks there still we're
just like you were gonna
high school quarterback you know I'd
Garrett Gilbert played in the AF is now
back up and Cleveland with Baker those
are like Travis guys that know played
against in high school in Patrick
mahomes are actually from pretty much
the same hometown you know five five
minutes apart so you know I grew an up
knew who that was him and my dad or his
dad and my dad we're good friends as I
was growing up so it's awesome to watch
or see like little Pat mahomes doing
some wild stuff machan stew watch him
play I moved to closer to San Antonio
but I definitely heard about him
definitely say like Texas like I'm sure
there's rumors like have you seen this
kid down there at Westlake of course of
course there see so Pat mahomes was kind
of coming up for a while now of course
and then you always check and see who's
getting recruited or at least I do who's
always going this you know from Texas to
other Texas schools to play college ball
and you know his name popped up going to
Tech and you know obviously you know it
known his dad for four years before that
and him a little bit so you know it was
great to see the success he had that's
probably you know the team that I'll
follow the most this year what about
Baker coming up because everybody
compared Baker to you it was like the
easy comparison similar height similar
hair color like everything were you
hearing about him as a young dude in
Texas complete but we played Lake Travis
where Garret Gilbert and Baker went to
school and you know miss playing him by
a year but you know you they always had
quarterbacks coming up every year it was
Jericho board and then Michael Brewer
ended up playing at Virginia Tech and
Texas Tech and then Baker came up right
after that and then you know the list of
do you want guys they had come out of
there was was yearly every year so you
know Baker
I think he's put himself in a great
position especially where he's out with
the guys they have around him and it'll
be fun to watch who was the best
quarterback in the NFL right now I still
I'm still a big Aaron Rodgers guy I
still think his mechanics the way throws
the ball how quick he's able to get it
out of his hands is like something that
nobody else in the league does it's
funny you say that this is what Aaron
Rodgers said about you before the draft
he said I like Johnny football I like
that he doesn't apologize for what
happened he was a 20 year old kid who
was enjoying life he had some more
opportunities fine
with his family growing up which a lot
of it college because the bazaar extra
benefit rules do some pretty cool things
and he didn't apologize
even back then Aaron Rodgers standing
for you
yeah no I think that was my attitude
about things back then and you know it
paints probably a little bit of a target
on your back when you don't apologize
both end of the day that's how it was
that's how it went and that's how Aaron
is too and Aaron gets in trouble for a
lot of the personal stuff as well but he
goes out there he handles his business
and he lives life the way he wants to
live it on a percent so you put him
number one where what is your who shirt
number one the quarterback all-time
all-time as far as their week are we
talking about the greatest quarterback
of all time are we talking about my
favorite to watch oh I want to know your
favorite favorite or the greatest and I
want to know the most talented cuz I
think those two are different yeah my
favorite quarterback of all time is Mike
big hands down watching him play for the
Falcons and even into the Eagles a
little bit but especially the Falcons I
was growing up I think I wore a
different Mike Vick jersey to school
probably Michael Vick was the best all
of that was the best a greatest
quarterback of all time I don't know how
you can go against Tom Brady I on how
you can do it just the success that
they've had year and then you're out
it's just keeps living a life like that
like you don't eat a strawberry at two
o'clock we rope cows milk on our calves
it's like non-stop it's what you see
with the greatest I mean it's what I saw
when I was around LeBron just doing
things that not a lot of people other do
a lot of other people do and that's what
makes him so good
and then most talented most talented is
it crazy for me to say that Patrick
mahomes might already be the most
talented quarterback of all time
yeah he's that's probably a little crazy
and a little early just just I'm a
little girl looking for some for some
longevity there for sure but as far as
what he has and you know the abilities
that he has they're definitely who would
you say is the most talented though I
mean as far as just throwing the ball
and as far as just you know watching it
come out of their hands and their
footwork and how they do certain things
my face
most ounces I still think is Rogers
Rogers yeah LeBron to be in that city
and for him you were with his marketing
firm and all that stuff in dealing with
it we get a glimpse now because of how
social media has changed with Taco
Tuesday and all that were and now we're
seeing his kids grow up so we've seen
LeBron for so long but you you were
there when we were still questioning
LeBron what what did you learn from
LeBron what did he teach you just from
like osmosis
I just think just how he carries himself
and how he does everything like you like
the thing you were saying about just the
little things that you would think that
are just so goofy and so unnecessary to
certain people that aren't involved
that's just routine for him that's just
what helps him be the best basketball
player on the face the earth every
single day and they had that planned out
365 for the last you know 18 15 years
whatever it's been every single day I
mean pretty much it probably doesn't
change a lot you know there's probably
days where he has free days but you know
five days of the week or probably
planned all the way around you know
yearly man and he was texting you all
the time you guys were he was the best
you know anything I could ask him or get
a chance to go over there and hang out
was you know a great learning experience
for me just how he carried himself and
how he does certain things and you know
it was it was extremely beneficial for
me to be around him you have seen the
inside of all of the monsters man it's
been fortunate are you gonna write a
book maybe one of these days I mean I
can I can go straight in for you I got
you man I don't know what it's gonna
growing up a Manziel now I'll work on
something we got to make it better
was there ever I think what's really
funny is is I asked this to Berkeley and
I asked us to save me all jacks enough
who when you were kind of going through
your [ __ ] they noticed you and they went
oh crap but you and your head were like
this person's noticing me like who hits
you with that non Drake or LeBron but
you were kind of fanboy on the inside I
went to a Alabama Notre Dame national
championship game in South Florida
after I had won the heisman and Vince
Vaughn was on the sidelines of the Notre
Dame side and I'd seen almost by every
movie he's ever been in and it was one
of those situations that you just spoke
about where you want to take a picture
with me I want to take a picture with
him and it was it was really really cool
it's fun so you're a big wedding
crashers oh yeah of course you big like
movie quotes guy um maybe not as much as
I used to be but you know I definitely
still have some of these insurers of my
top five movies of all time it's mature
it too when nature calls
of course classic shut up you don't
believe that what's it your acid what's
it your top five I'm happy gilmore for
sure today good night sir shake and bake
shake and bake I'm just looking through
my notes you I thought part of what kind
of added to your legacy too was the
Alabama game that's when it blew the
[ __ ] out
I'm just curious have you ever has Sabin
ever said anything to you have you ever
had a cool conversation with him
because I feel like it was a defining I
don't know if there is such thing as
like a cool conversation with Nick Saban
if so you Nick Saban were to walk into
this room right now and come into the
casino it would be like there's a dark
cloud that's following over him with
thunder and lightning and like just this
dark like ominous like following that
comes behind him it's not very big but
he maybe he's by far probably the most
intimidating guy that walks into the
room he just has that stigma balichek
they both have that energy where like
they don't have to say it but do not
mess with me yeah I'd be careful what
you say because there's probably one of
those times where you know you may just
be like what are you talking about and
just call you out on it a little bit of
a conversation I don't know if there was
much of one you know just quick probably
in passing but I just remember him
walking into the room and getting that
feeling of that that cloud following him
everywhere like he was just just
powerful is this a thing anymore and I
think it's probably dead good times oh
good times I know I keep bringing out
the old [ __ ] for what I like to explain
to my listeners too is how hard it is to
be in the NFL and what you were talking
about earlier with everyone trying to
fight too
in its that battle you know I can you
explain to fans that don't understand
because they see guys and they leave the
league just how [ __ ] hard it is it's
just a constant fight I remember getting
into my first training camp and you know
looking at the roster and you know being
a young guy hanging out with these guys
for the month that you're there and
training camp going through it you know
I'm sitting there looking at the roster
like okay this sides gonna make the team
this guy for sure just based off how
they're performing in camp or just kind
of you know how I saw them as a player
or what I had seen from them in the past
training camp cuts come come around you
know two weeks later and probably twenty
or thirty of those guys that I thought
were 100% gonna make the team weren't
there and we went with two rookie
running backs and went with a you know
undrafted free agent receiver two of
them and these guys that were played you
don't have a lot of excess spots once
the roster gets a lockdown once it gets
down to fifty four you got five or six
receivers we got two or three tight ends
you know you have a couple backup
offensive linemen but everything really
gets shrunk down to two just a small
size of what you had you know in camp
and it's always going younger it's
always going cheaper and it was a big
shock for me after my first training
camp for sure watching twenty guys who I
had knew we're gonna make the team we
sent home and you're just looking around
and you realize the business of it all
Oh 100%
I knew sitting there looking knowing
football watching these guys go out and
play a hundred percent I'm like oh this
guy's been here had a good year last
year blah blah blah none of it matter
and we went with probably eight or nine
guys who were you know rookies who were
cheaper and came in and were younger I
say this to this day that you had the
greatest Pro day of all time I thought
it was the smartest marketing the
smartest formulation of it who went out
there shoulder pads helmet hip hop
blasting get the coaches around in a
circle tell them what you're gonna do
because it was so perfect because the
whole time it was like Johnny down four
and you wore pants nobody wears [ __ ]
pads for their pro day nobody wears a
helmet and the music was going you had a
pub well I thought it was one of the
greatest pro day performance I've ever
seen
I think people probably took it in and
lumped in with a little bit of this
man's out guys probably just doing more
and doing extra like he always was
before me it was it was hey if I go into
training camp or I go into a workout for
this team you know I'm not gonna ever
play football without shoulder pads or a
helmet on right this is how I'm gonna
throw if I'm throwing in a game or if
I'm throwing in practice and it was you
know something that kind of took me a
little bit of coming around through and
George Whitefield my quarterback coach
the time was just kind of talked me into
it a little bit so you know it was it
was a great day I had a chance to have a
president Bush there all right he was
there oh she was there and when I was W
or Herman W know Harvard and so he came
just to watch you yeah I got a chance to
meet him the night before and sat around
and talked with him for a little bit in
the ended up coming the next day about
you know ten minutes into the workout
you know the doors open and secret
service starts walking in and he's
driving a golf cart just completely
through the workout just kind of kind of
like he owns the place as he should have
it was it was amazing I still have
people that come out to me in College
Station and talk to me about it all the
time just George Bush rollin in to watch
you throw what's rolling in damn that's
awesome and then when you see guys like
Kyler Murray coming out you were not
like you're kind of a smaller stature
quarterback we've seen Russell Wilson
Baker Kyler true breeze it seems as
though that's doable now like it I felt
like we were calling them outliers but
now we're seeing it so prevalent I'm
just curious
is it that much harder for a smaller
quarterback in the pocket if you can
play you can play you know whether you
find lanes or whether you can see over
and I'm sure you know being six seven
and being able to see over everything is
probably a little bit easier but at the
end of the day know if you can play ball
and you can make the throws that you
need to and see what you need to it
doesn't really matter and I think every
year that a short quarterback or an
undersized quarterback gets drafted I
think it just continues to help the
cause for guys moving forward
you know if you can play you can play to
to the homies out there the 33% that are
listening you've learned a lot in life
and I'm curious I have a lot of guys
that are high school college they listen
to the show and a lot of them hit me up
and they're kind of looking for
inspiration and I'm curious what's the
message that you pass on to young people
now recently it's been you know the
thing that I probably learned the most
is you get in or you get out what you
put into it whether it's you know the
work you put into the weight room or the
time you put watching film by the time
you put into you know your craft as a
whole you get back what you put into it
you know I think that's the biggest
thing you know I was you know bus with a
lot of talent could have put you know
more time and more effort into into the
main thing that would have you know paid
off longer down longer down the road I
still think you're destined for big [ __ ]
I appreciate it
and the reason I say that is you have
your sense of self and once you have
that you're golden because a lot of
people are trying to be something their
whole [ __ ] lives
you are unabashedly you and now you're
sitting in the wake of you and I I don't
think this journeys over by any long so
I think you know that too I just don't
know what it is you're gonna do and I
think there's something exciting about
that too and I think when everything
kind of happened you know I was 18 or 19
years old so baby you know it feels like
I've been around for for a long time and
I'm sitting here at 26 years old today
so you know some guys get into the
league at 23 or 24 so I still feel like
I have a window of no opportunity in my
aging where I'm at right now to be able
to capitalize on and it's just waiting
on the opportunity to present itself and
they make the most of it what do you
think about Eagles fans yeah I think
there's passion is it gay oh don't play
it nice are you a Cowboys fan I am a
Cowboys fan but I have no no you can say
no Giants I kind of want to put a bet on
the Eagles Cowboys this year if you're
down
don't think about it you'll think about
it I don't know if I'm that big of a
Cowboys fan I'm not really
you know I'm pulling form you asked me
who I like this year I like the boys but
as far as being a fan you know after
playing in the NFL after being on a team
I don't know if I'm much of you know
just a fan of any one team in general
probably more players the board up there
Super Bowl odds you've told me you like
the Cowboys but if you had to bet one
team to win the Super Bowl Saints Saints
I think they're gonna take a step back
this year yeah I don't I think this is
probably you know one of their last you
know good runs that they have in them
and I think the people that they have
around with the experience they do I
don't think they'll take a step so you
believe this is Drew Brees Sean Payton
in a room going this might be our last
freaking chance we got to get it done
all the stars align yeah I think you
know look at what's happened in the last
two seasons going into the playoffs is
is kind of leave as bitter a taste in
your mouth as as possible especially
last year it's just you know a shock how
everything kind of turned out especially
with how well I felt they played even in
that last game so I feel they did I feel
they're on the brink and they've been
that way for a while and you know you
look back you get your receiver sign you
get them happy they have weapons around
you ask for more they they hope they
have some guys so you know you look at
their division was at Tampa Atlanta
Carolina and Carolina so you don't
really know what's interesting too is I
think about Virginia when in the
national championship the year after
they lose to a 16cm
and I think about the Saints Minneapolis
miracle in the divisional round comeback
championship game pass interference it
would be wild if something awful
happened in the Superbowl to prevent it
but I think what you're saying it's sort
of like the last-ditch Saints run for a
Super Bowl this is it because with Drew
Brees is contract and all those other
guys coming and just unknowns there's so
many unknowns
and he we talked about Brady be at 42
maybe breezes right there too yeah 100%
I think he's been as good as any guy in
the NFL for the last you know eight ten
years it's been it's been awesome to
watch so I've been a huge big big drew
brees guy for you know as long as I can
remember so that's that's really who I'm
pulling for homies I need you to get
into his mentions and celebrate this
[ __ ] he is a part of the 33% now
which means we will always have his back
wherever you go if it's if it is the XFL
I might have to put the jersey up in the
studio got you if it's NFL it's
definitely going up in the studio so
wherever you go my man we're excited for
you
can I get some noise please for Johnny
for a shitty guy Johnny Manziel you
feeling good feeling good Johnny Manziel
is gonna take us out doing a freestyle
that's all you baby look it's all you no
I'm just kidding all right I always talk
to you later
[Music]